these are the weakest quirks first up we
have deku's Mom's Quirk her only ability
is to attract small objects towards her
very slowly people like to say that her
Quirk could be stronger if she trained
it but that's speculation then we have
the luminescence Quirk that made a
newborn baby glow cute but that's about
it next is a guy from bakugou and deku's
middle school class who could make his
nose a bit bigger impressive then yet
another guy from that same class whose
Quirk is just to pull out his eyes from
his socket wow great ability finally we
have the transference Quirk that was
initially used by the first one for all
user its only ability is to be
transferred to someone else and the
original user didn't even know that he
had it until it combined with a second
powerful Quirk but any Quirk can become
strong when combined with a much
stronger Quirk subscribe now for more
mha videos